[Music]
all right so let's talk a little bit
more about multicultural and because I
think multiculturalism has worked pretty
well in America we are the melting pot
everyone comes here from all over the
earth they come here they bring their
traditions but you become part of the
greater tradition of America this is
something that I'm very proud to live in
this country for and I think we've done
it like no other place in the history of
the world is our experiment of
multiculturalism different and perhaps
better than the way you guys have done
it in Europe it's a mile of being in
America I love that you will you people
will chant USA USA I love that I mean I
appreciate that political and other
places so I've seen it maybe on the
Trump trail but I love that I love the
people will wear the American flag or
have stuff that is kind of American flag
about them or WL or window right there
what do you see you can't get away from
it
gotta bug all right you know you I when
I used to I do so when I lived in New
York I used to do run club every Sunday
and before we ran we sang the national
anthem that kind of makes no sense to a
British person because okay well this
thing the national anthem before we have
a little jog that would never happen it
you do not hear the national anthem at
all in the UK here it feels like the
first thing you should be or at least
you are and if you're not well you know
whatever is American and that is work
brilliantly and I feel that you've got
it right and I I'm urging at all times
whenever I'm speaking on Fox or any of
the stuff I do it's always to say look
at England look at the UK do not be us
do not become us that's always my plea
to America do not look at us as the
thing you don't want to be and when I
look at the UK I know that we don't have
multiculturalism not at all we have
ghettos of individual cultures we have
mono cultures living alongside each
other so you can even go to areas of
London and you'll know if you're in the
Afghanistan Lee area the Somalian area
the Eritrean area or the Pakistani area
and the interesting thing for me is when
I went to the jungle in Calais where the
migrants live
they get on the lorries if they can get
on is I went to an area I was looking
for a lady with her young son actually
turned out to be a girl but she dressed
him as a boy so that the daughter
wouldn't get taken from or attacked by
the men I was upsetting enough but I
went to look for her in the Afghani area
and they were like they were kind of
really were too shocked though it was
like she was Somalian but she wouldn't
be here this is the Afghani area and
that was in the migrant camp of Calais
now you take that and you bring that to
London the same they come here they
don't mix it's not multicultural and
every old historic argument conflict
tension that they had in their home
country they brought and they brought it
with them and that's why you see the
banlieue of Paris's you know those lines
are delineated where the hand grenades
fall and that's the same in Sweden
marked by this culture or that we don't
have multiculturalism yeah so so I'm
glad you made that distinction though
because when you say you're against
multiculturalism you're actually you're
not really against Navi culturalism the
idea of it you're against the way it's
been put into practice put into practice
and and the the lies the disconnect er I
think miss truth whatever where you want
to package that up so it sounds better
but the outright nonsense that Britain
is a multicultural triumph no you guys
are I think Italy actually is still
maintaining there's something about
being Italian there I feel it's very
strong food great and when you're in
southern Italy even though the migrant
boats are coming but it's being Italian
matters more and I really enjoy that
when I was there but we haven't got that
right in the UK we have not achieved
multiculturalism in its true sense we
have achieved a bunch of monocultures
that still hate each other I'm wearing
amongst that is anyone politically
talking about this in a way that you
think is right like is anyone really
addressing the heart of it now we've
lost where you guys like Corbin who's
embracing it right and then we've lost
that the UK has lost its way at the
moment so after brexit you know I was
child but I was so excited
you know there's Farraj and I kind of
have been pushing Bret's I was like the
female for hours
I guess I don't know what I was I they
soak out an edition but so yeah you know
so that was breakfast it we have our
pails up and then trouble in life
couldn't be better and then now we've
lost all of that because we have the
snack election and and the people that
voted remain used it as their
opportunity to have effectively a second
referendum so we don't have anybody that
standing up for making Britain great
again we don't have someone putting
forward the ideas that we need to reduce
the amount of state involvement in our
health care to over a halt our schooling
system so that only the brightest and
the best get through to reduce the
number of individuals being educated to
death for no reason because they were
barely literate before they even got to
university we need to pull back the
state and we don't have anybody talking
like that in the UK but we do have Trump
in America so I'm yeah I'm all you go
year grad for us all right but I guess
but he's not part of the government no
he's discredited him largely he's not
part of the government he's not standing
again he's not currently part of a party
and you keep her falling away because I
have to brexit they didn't have a place
because the Conservatives really took
their ground so I'd say it's a very
disappointing place in terms of when
people talk about you know I listen to
the liberal comics at politican saying
about how these are dark times in
America is dark times your dark time
what you're wearing honey that is dark
then but you go to the UK for someone
like is a breakfast here without anybody
to look to for hope and you go this is
dark times we may not get breakfast it
we don't have anybody who wants to make
Britain great again and we don't have a
voice that's going to represent us just
yet what do you make of some of the
movement on the right in the UK and that
are happening throughout Europe you know
like the EDL and pegida and all that I
think the issue with as soon as the
label many labels are ineffective now
racist I think is ineffective
Islamophobe is ineffective because
enough of us can see that we're being
done harmed by a religion that we should
work out how to work alongside but I
think in terms of being far-right that
label still has meaning and it's
sufficient as a label to discredit
anything that therefore is said by that
individual so as soon as you can chuck a
far-right label on it that excuse not to
even listen not even here and even is
that individual let's take Tommy
Robinson is outside a court protesting
against Muslim grooming gangs rape
squads
rather if we weren't using true terms
he'll be discredited and ridiculed and
just pushed away because he's far-right
and of course that doesn't fit in the
hierarchy of correct thought which then
I think just actually reads support for
Tommy Robinson because if you why I've
had him on the show I you know I've had
Marg it on a couple times yeah but you
know I imagine was talking about him
just a couple weeks ago right here and
they obviously have major issues you
know and Tommy showed up at the offices
it's caused all sorts of problem but for
the most part I think Tommy does again
make a distinction between ideas and
people he has gone out of he's left
organizations that were truly racist and
then when people see the way he's
dismissed they go wait a minute he's not
really he's talking about some that
we need to talk about and look at the
way he's treated and then they quietly
are them supporting him I'd rather have
all this stuff out in the open I never
everybody having this debate I agree
with you entirely he has a massive
support base and he is able to get to
support base but that support brace does
not have reach so it's a large number
it's a big volume of people but they're
very concentrated around each other so
their own little echo chamber it doesn't
have reach into the establishment or to
the news media or to any of the
mainstream because they've managed to
pass over to the far right and they've
also managed so when we had the attack
on a mosque well there was a guy that
drove into some individuals outside the
East London mosque well-known for not
necessarily being the most tolerant of
places just to be clear that that was
the mask that the Westminster attackers
came from right yes that I believe
that's correct I believe that's correct
but I do know think the relative nature
may be I'm not sure whether the
Westminster attacker came from there
there was a history of that mosque
having issues in terms of its okay the
extremism that it was alleged to have
bred but my point is as soon as that
attack happened which was just one guy
in a van that kind of went a bit crazy
that became that Tommy Robertson than to
blame
and the news agenda went straight to
Tommy I thought about that night on
Twitter yeah which is very silencing
actually because then even for his
supporters you don't be affiliated with
someone that's being said as being
responsible for that clearly he have no
responsibility for that but that's what
the media have created they have
portrayed him in a dark place and
actually that is where you end up over
on the far harddrive right so apparently
ideas and words do matter but only
depending on which way they come from
yeah exactly why really bizarre exactly
right and I think so many I wouldn't
want to ever try and sigh speak for
Britain but certainly people that do
maybe support what I say I think are
frustration is that we see so much hate
enacted on our own girls our children
people go to a concert people going out
for dinner you know 12 inch hunting
knife pushed through the face of a woman
eating you know on London Bridge we're
not we're not supposed to talk about
that or suggest that that's linked to
religion and we're certain not supposed
to report that and if we do we're told
that maybe we're being racist whereas
the encouragement the support to report
any kind of hate crime done by somebody
maybe like myself
yeah something I've said a tweet is very
there's a lot of funding behind that
kind of reporting so I'm glad you
mention that because it's one of the
things that I've seen on Twitter which I
think is truly what it would be most
outrageous ludicrous insane things that
I've seen on Twitter has been a few
times where which is the which is the
local police that is Ella
London is Met Police the Metropolitan
Police come for me so I'm not in their
area most tweeted things whatever it is
you've tweeted and then they requested
that people report report you and
refined other things that you've said
and all this stuff for hate speech or
whatever terms that they're using even
though as you said I've done no violence
I'm not calling for violence blah blah
blah blah blah now and they're literally
word police now yes so the word police
are strong and just if I give maybe two
or three examples so that so I suppose
this sort of woman thing mom number
three kids married regular house quite
like gardening secret gardener on the
side so this is me and maybe my network
of other fairly rubbish mums who aren't
that good at it and fairly crap
gardeners that's how I see myself with
my network right yeah so then I write in
a column in a national newspaper one of
the papers I used to work for
that column became the focus of the head
of the UN HR and he said that I was one
of the causes of all of the issues
against multicultural in the UK I was
brought in under caution by the major
crime and homicide command interviewed
by two people on a tape and then that
was taken to the CPS the Crown
Prosecution Service to see if I would go
up to be put given jail time for a
column in a national paper I have been
reported to social services for my
children because people say my twitter
feed is so fierce I must be hurting my
children so social service has come just
to check because they're obliged to and
I respect that I've also been threatened
I was called when I was in Australia I
was going to be repatriated to the UK
because of the tweet where I called a
nurse who to come back with Ebola I
called her a bola Bom and so I was going
to be repatriated to the UK for that and
I've had two further incidents at police
in my home telling me I needed to pay at
the police station for tweets so I am
heavily policed and my liberty I suppose
is under threat for the words that I
type who is policing the police anymore
so when I see that or I see Tommy Oz and
these periscopes where he'll be kicked
out of a bar and he'll get the camera
right in the in the policeman's face and
they'll say oh I didn't do anything I
was just out of bar and someone hit me
over the head with something or someone
screaming me and they'll be like no no
no you're just by being here you're
you're upsetting people or whatever it
is you think I didn't break any law as
far as I can tell by anything but you
just said I'm breaking now I've seen
similar things I think with anne-marie
waters I mean just the collection of
people regardless of what you think of
them that be raw is being turned against
them for nothing illegal I mean if
anyone policing the police is this an
issue that anyone's picking up and are
any liberals talking about this no but I
think there is a growing movement I can
feel it through my emails through the
people that get in touch with me through
some of the stuff that I do I even have
people from inside the BBC and inside
the Guardian newspaper which is the big
left-wing establishment newspaper I have
some people inside there that email me
now to tell me things because they
respect what I'm trying to do which is
maybe just have other views heard or
just illuminate some things that we have
going on but and I see that the way the
police operates in a way the
we fight back all the way that we police
the police I think is by me using my
platform to show what they're doing so
Bedford sure police have just invested a
massive Sun of sum of money trying to
get people to report Twitter feeds of
people like me race occasional from the
right it's saying don't cross the line
like where will this person who's
actually a trump supporter cross the
line for the user so Bedford sure police
who've spent all this money on this are
actually rated the worst police force in
the country they are they were reported
as being unable to function as a police
source so I then tweet that so they see
that the amount they're vesting on
trying to police me and my Twitter feed
versus the fact that they are the one of
the worst performing police stations in
the country and I think by adding you're
giving publicity to showing them to say
listen why don't you focus on your
issues I think the same I had after a
lot of the incidents and the violence in
Manchester with the bombing I had some
people from inside the police force
email me to say that actually the Imams
at the local mosque decide who the two
police officers are that they will
approve to go and patrol their area and
the Imams they're in control of the
police officers coming out of there even
yeah so then I take that email with the
permission of the defender make it
anonymous and post that up and there
were some things that came off the back
of that so I see my job now as helping
to expose why we have so many systemic
level problems about the way our country
is going and those sorts of things when
I'm told that Imams are selecting the
police officers who are Muslim police
officers to be allowed to go near their
areas that's when I go into this but you
know the thing we talked about with the
pictures that isn't pieces of the puzzle
that make a picture once you find out
you're Imams are picking your police for
you that can police them it mosques you
start to go down that route of wondering
precisely what's going on yeah you know
I'm picturing one of my favorite movies
be for Vendetta which did take place in
in Britain you know there's that moment
when the when the police officer is
putting it all together and he just
tells a story and he says to his his you
know sidekick basically he's like this
is going to sound crazy but yours might
hear and that's how I feel like I almost
died Mac sees the world I guess a little
bit in pictures anyway or I visualize
things
I feel I feel like I take my little
piece of that me at the camp at Calais
Here I am in Libya and in the Med Here I
am in sweden in no-go zones Here I am
with a guy telling me that the Imams
pick the police that were allowed to
police Here I am in the schools with the
children with their Clinton Mints and
all of a sudden this thing starts to
take the shape of something that I'm
almost too scared of and I don't know I
can't stop now I have to keep going I
think but it's interesting the number of
things where they're trying to take me
down with police or with social services
at my children or however which way they
come for me yeah I sense though that
they can't scare you
I said no wavering in you immunity no I
I feel utterly fearless and I don't mean
that in a weird sort of like the
feminist yell oh my god my of
nativity or cosmetics aha I was about to
do a goddamn thing with Madonna what
would be yes
I have no hat and I'm proud of
that but I I am definitely fearless
because I know ultimately little things
amassed to me are my family my children
my husband and then being healthier I am
alpha female all the way and then being
a healthy ish as woot can be and happy
that all the matters so that's it now
outside of that other things I care
about which is my country and I will
carry on
you're telling me truth you emailing me
about what's gone on your police station
or inside the garden or inside the BBC
or you're misrepresenting white people I
will talk about that and you can't take
anything away from me you may take away
my job at the newspaper you may have
just managed to get me kicked off my
radio show it doesn't matter there will
be another platform if enough people
feel that I give them a voice and that's
why I applaud what you do what you guys
are doing because you are self-funded
you are the people that want to hear you
are paying for you and I love this idea
that that will be the new truth is that
people will pay to be able to hear the
truths that commissioners and TV
commissioners and people that work in
the media industry have tried to silence
and this is the new evolution of the US
and I think I will be doing a similar
thing hope
Faline coming soon in the UK where
perhaps the people that feel they're
being silenced can help fund a space
where we will continue to speak and we
will evolve over the viruses and we are
the new anti biotic that will say no
we're going to keep being heard and that
feels powerful and makes me feel more
fearless that was a nice ending to this
interview but I'm half done with you you
oh I'm not done like that once I'm done
that felt like the natural ending but
I'm an effect but you know what I to go
off what you just said there I think the
most beautiful thing that I didn't
realize - for about a year when I went
independent was that I get those same
emails from you from all of it I get
from Christian conservatives and I get
from progressives and I get from far
lefties and I get from libertarians or
whatever from all over late all over the
world atheists in Saudi Arabia a whole
freakin thing and it's like be all these
people support what I'm doing and it's
like I all I can do is do what I think
is right when you have that kind of
plurality of support I can't eat if I
was I've said this so many times but if
I was to try to sell out tomorrow you
tell I genuinely wouldn't know which way
to sell now truly I mean that is really
the truth so all I can do is what I
think is right yes and I saw that and I
saw that there for the people that are
funding what you're doing they're not
funding you to say a certain thing it's
not that weird funded onething they're
funding you just to have the platform
and if they don't like what you said
they're also going to tell you that well
they also have one degree you have the
opportunity to stop funding but maybe
you'll pick up another funder over there
but what I love the idea is that these
is best in this institution the
establishment that maybe could be linked
to the Soros kind of program of mass
movement people or may not very let's
now go there but the idea that you will
now move over the top of them and have
your own platform that they cannot
filter through you cannot have a
commissioner who's a lefty that says no
we don't need her talking you've gone
beyond that I think is incredibly
powerful and I also think those people
need you and that's why you can't stop
it becomes almost like a religion I know
I know
yeah but as I told you before we started
as of this interview of taking basic two
vacations on until September 5th
hopefully the world will miss it now now
but then I kept taking it the world ends
literally if it ends while I'm gone am I
going to
jump back on Twitter just for a second
just to say goodbye or now just let me
know just do the best thing you can do
if the world is about to end never be
back on Twitter don't even do don't even
do the rhythm report as much as I love
it
you know let's all get a sense of
ourselves let's get over here let's look
in the sunset let's remember the
beautiful things that happened in your
life open up about one grill but
otherwise it sounded like a right Emma
nasty right that's nice that usually
let's talk for a second about any
frustrations that you might have with
your team do you think the right or do
you think the Trump people or the
Conservatives or whatever you want to
call all that are they doing anything
wrong here do you see any flaws in your
side and anything up that we should know
about of course the right do so many
things wrong and I would never in any
way think that my loyalty is goes beyond
anything they do wrong that I wouldn't
call them out on it I think one thing we
don't do enough of is just being very
true about what we're celebrating and
what we're actually celebrating what
we're actually all about in my personal
opinion is freedom we're all about
liberty we are the true I think
libertarians we are the people that once
more state want you to choose what you
do beat what you want to be live how you
want to live do it don't do it that's
why I think we're all about and I don't
think we get that message across clearly
at all conservatives always come across
as the former ones are sensible ones the
ones that are about war the ones that
want to put more people in police
stations the ones that want to lock
people up in jail I don't think that's
the truth of us we've given ourselves
this weird kind of outfit this uniform
has been terribly strict and terribly
proper actually we're the dirtiest
hookers on the block because if they
live your life and we need to get more
of that message across but we just want
you to live it well live it within the
rules of law and order we want you to
pay your taxes be happy and have your
family and be proud of them and that's
the more positive conservative message
that I want to help spread that's what I
think we need to do to make Britain
great again as well and I think we need
much less state in our lives because
wherever the state interferes we
typically fail and our National Health
Service if I could make another plea to
America would be Peas look carefully
beyond the headlines at the UK National
Health Service because it is falling on
it's our
because it is the worst of all solutions
do not look to Western Europe as I heard
said last night like some great kind of
Golden Goose in the sky of what you want
to become you don't want that yeah you
want private health insurance health is
not a right I think health is a good and
the more we see it that way the more we
drive the free market to create the
solution for us the better we are all
right well I think that was too good
closing statements but I'll give you
okay I'll give you an opportunity for
one more
so just surmising all this and then i
think you're going to stick on for a
quick rapid-fire thing that we're doing
for our special wedding trims only um
what's next for you if you can please do
just continuing this adventure so I
think I would like to say that I'm
massively strategic in my operations but
I also have a kind of cunning plan
behind it in so inside is this engine of
determination that I will not be taken
down that I will stand strong and that
it member is very clear you're not
hiding that word that's the engine that
drives it I think they're the way the
road I'm going down so there is a book
that will come out in September that
Katie Hopkins rude and I guess it is
quite rude which is like kind of the
making of me and why I'm the way I am my
father would say is incredibly
problematic and I'm going to be doing a
new program which will be about linking
funding to ensuring people have their
voices heard that's coming out the back
end and is their here which will be into
2018 and we will bypass the
establishment we will bypass the
commissioners and we will bypass all the
left wing that seem to want to narrate
how England is which I'm not having any
more of and then into next year I've
been doing more of the same but trying
to stand for something trying to build
some kind of way of taking a new
conservative force forward that is about
living life positively about a small
state and about you know bringing
Britain back to what we thought was
great in a really positive way we do
embrace multiculturalism but we do it
well where we do have schools that
function and allow people to leave when
frankly they don't need educating
anymore
and where we do say that you are going
to take responsibility and
accountability yourself but we'll
support you in it
that's kind of my past and I'm kind of
excited at all times about it
but I would say to anybody my detractors
that created me is that we will keep
evolving we will keep being better and
we will keep being heard and you will
not silence us
that's three endings now well I guess
probably more does a man need that's it
I will not laugh you for any more it was
a pleasure talking to you and I think
more than anything else because of the
fact that I see what people say about
you and all those things and I've had
this a few times on the show where I
have been byte guest on that people say
horrible things and then you sit across
from somebody for an hour and less I
gonna do I left you the charlatan of all
time I see a pretty decent person thank
you yes fine it was a pleasure talking
to you and for more on Katie follow her
on the Twitter for all her adventures
and for the police the which one is it
again Oh better chip Anita and what
they're up to it they're constantly
watching her it's at Katie Hopkins
[Music]
you